okay no really you don't have to
apologize for saying something that's
true this week sportscaster Jim Rome
apologized for tweeting that marching
bands are for dorks right because nobody
wet ins panties like a fat guy walking
around in circles playing get down
tonight on a clarinet with a mop on his
head and while we're on the subject
everyone in the marching band who's not
playing the trumpet or the drums can
stay home cuz no one can hear you
new rule moms returning this play-doh
cake returning this play-doh cake
mountain toy because they're offended by
its shape have to stop acting like
that's the embarrassing part the
embarrassing is part is when you get
home and have to explain to your kids
why you have an even bigger one in the
panic room new rule now that Michelle
Bachmann is proudly tweeting photos of
dollar 98 gasps just like she promised
when she ran for president
someone has to break it to her that
she's not president
we keep telling you dear you lost you're
not the president and that's not the
White House that's the tool shed in the
backyard yeah new rule if you spend a
hundred and twenty dollars on vessel the
new smart cup that tells you what's
inside it then congratulations you're
dumber than a cup
finally finally a solution for all those
times you have no idea what you're
drinking is it beer is it coffee let's
ask the cup
who could possibly need this other than
women dating Bill Cosby
new rule the NYPD must stop acting like
the only thing black people do is run
from them and shoot at them believe it
or not there are some black New Yorkers
who won't run and can't shoot they're
called the Knicks